[Music]
let us consider a classic relativity
scenario your friend gets on a rocket
ship and blasts off towards Mars at
nearly the speed of
light during this journey his clocks
tick slower his lengths
contract and when he arrives to his
destination he has aged less than
everyone back on Earth
but that's not the only side to this
story because from your friend's
perspective events transpired somewhat
differently his clocks actually ticked
at a normal
rate and it was in fact the distance
between Earth and Mars that in
Contracting allowed him to reach his
destination in a shorter
time meanwhile before he reaches Mars he
perceives that less time has actually
elapsed on your clock
since you were traveling at near the
speed of light relative to
him only once he decelerates to land on
Mars will his and your perception of
time and space once more be
reconciled this is the theory of
relativity in a nutshell a theory often
described by the average person as
totally
trippy W though mathematically
consistent the theory offers no vision
of a shared reality for its observers
and upon its conception it ushered in a
reign of conscious Centric solipsism an
unphysical ratio signation that has
endured uncontested for nearly a century
and a
quarter well today get ready to
unplug because it turns out there is a
completely physical explanation one
devoid of any notion of relative space
or time that we can give to this this
picture this is
dialect and welcome to Matrix
[Music]
Theory there exists before you a pencil
that one day inexplicably shrinks
now you'd like to use physics to explain
why this pencil shrunk but coming up
with an explanation is well
difficult you see you'd have to posit
some sort of physical mechanism or maybe
chemical process to account for this
contraction which would involve a lot of
speculation and theorizing and gosh that
sounds like hard
work but then you have a brilliant idea
why do physics when you can just do
math that is you realize you can assert
that nothing physical actually happened
to the pencil at all and instead of the
pencil shrinking it was in fact the
background that
grew see the pencil started out at 5
units of length relative to the
background but once the background grows
it now only spans four units of
length so it was the coordinates that
actually shrank not your
pencil indeed you claim that the length
of your pencil is absolute or
invariant then you fix a local
background to it such that your
background never grows your pencil never
shrinks and you never have to do any
physics woo job well
done but now along comes another
Observer with a pencil that also
inexplicably sh rinks from 5 to 4
units you demand they give a physical
explanation for this but they aren't
having it if you don't have to do
physics why should
they indeed they claim their pencil is
the invariant one and yours is the one
that actually
shrank you see they assert that because
your pencil shrink you grew your
background to compensate for this
shrinking and that you are using this
inflated background to see their own
pencil which of course now appears to
span less
coordinates now this catches you off
guard at first but being clever you
realize you can turn this argument
around on them and say no your pencil
never shrank rather as you first
asserted their pencil did and they are
the one wielding an inflated background
to thus see your own pencil as
shortened
now in the absence of any Global
background there will be no way to know
which of you is telling the
truth worse if you manage to bring the
pencils side by side for comparison they
are found to be the same length meaning
each of you can now claim that the
other's pencil physically grew upon
leaving its
frame causing its observer's respective
inflated background to deflate and thus
for them to see a corresponding growth
in the opposite
pencil indeed in this construct where
all observers are equally entitled to
not doing physics one beholds in lie of
any actual explanations just symmetry
perfect beautiful mathematical
[Music]
symmetry what
is how do
you
[Music]
special relativity is undoubtedly a
mathematically beautiful symmetric
Theory but there has always been another
explanation that is the lorenzian one
the one which posits the existence of an
all-pervading ether through which light
travels as a wave at a constant
velocity according to this
interpretation clocks in motion with
respect to the ether physically tick
more
slowly while objects in motion
physically
contract formalistic this yields a
theory that is equivalent to Einstein's
capable of making all the same
mathematical predictions as well as
explaining all the same experimental
findings despite this equivalence for
much of History these theories have been
viewed as dichotomous opposites distinct
and competing interpretations such such
that one can only be championed at the
expense of the other but this bad blood
has led almost everyone to overlook
something extraordinary and
critical Einstein and Loren's theories
are not merely just formalistic
equivalent rather they are in fact two
indispensable halves of a greater
hole taken apart neither achieves true
logical coherency but together they can
produce a theory with unrivaled
explanatory
power to understand this Union let us
start by observing that what makes
Loren's Theory unique is its
fundamentally ontological
nature that is it offers us a hypothesis
about what constitutes the real
world meaning the world whose existence
is not relative to our perception of
it indeed prior to Einstein every
advancement in physics generally
required making such a
hypothesis to explain the workings of
the universe a physicist or natural
philosopher was expected to propose some
sort of physical content which existing
outside of the mind would serve as the
causal mechanism for observable
phenomena mathematics was then employed
to help make these models precise and
better describe such
phenomena since Einstein however the the
offering up of physical content is no
longer in Vogue and math instead of
aiding in the description of observable
phenomena now serves as the cause of
those
phenomena relativity initiated this
trend for as Einstein himself admitted
special relativity was never a theory
about
reality rather it was only ever a theory
about measurement a convenient
mathematical
framework but by fail faing to offer any
physical content the theories
mathematics was soon latched onto as
being its
content fast forward 120 years and you
have a shocking number of physicists who
sincerely believe that it is hyperbolic
manowski and geometry which causes
rather than merely describes time
dilation and length
contraction but the representation is
not the
reality and we can see that Einstein's
theory was as a opposed to being
ontological in nature rather merely
epistemological to unify it with
lorenzian ontology then requires
advancing what is termed The Matrix
hypothesis the hypothesis is simple it
posits that there is a real world a
world of physical causal content
existing independent of our minds but
that our perception of that reality does
not and may not ever align with the
actual thing
indeed math measurement language
abstraction the things which modern
physics asserts causes observable
phenomena these things in truth belong
to the world of perception and
Consciousness encasing our minds there
like a womb one to which we may be
forever irrevocably plugged
in
[Music]
in the real world there exists the
medium of The Ether and some singular
frame in which it is physically at rest
clocks that are set in motion with
respect to this medium will tick more
slowly and objects set in motion will
physically
contract this is the first half of the
picture the lorenzian half the second
half of the picture is what happens when
the Observer is put in motion with
respect to the
medium here is where the Observer enters
the Matrix or as a consequence of
Einstein's Axiom begins to construct a
false projection of their reality that
does not correspond to the actual
one to understand this let's imagine an
observer traveling at near the speed of
light relative to the
medium when they fire a beam of light in
the direction of travel this beam moves
at a constant speed C through the medium
relative to The Observer the beam thus
travels very
slowly but thanks to the one-way speed
of light problem an observer has no way
of knowing
this they can only make a judgment about
what this speed of light was relative to
them once the beam has bounced off of
something and returned to
them what Einstein's Axiom stipulates
then is that the simplest assumption
mathematically The Observer can make is
that the light beam traveled at the same
speed there and back relative to
them but this assumption is only
mathematical not physical and of course
back in the real world the light beam
did not travel at the same velocity
relative to The Observer there and back
the Observer therefore has to adjust
their Notions of time and space in order
to maintain this assumed
isotropy this is where the relativity of
space and time comes from it's not a
metaphysically deep discernment of what
reality is or is not rather it's a
mathematical contrivance intended to
sidestep our inherent uncertainty in the
knowledge of the one-way speed of
light to understand how this works let's
divide the world of two given observers
into four essential
partitions in the first two partitions
each Observer has their own local
frame which encompasses anything
co-moving with them and which can be
constructed using physical objects such
as rulers and
clocks but these frames can't be used to
make physical measurements for things in
motion relative to
them for this an observer needs a second
frame a background
frame this background frame is not
physical but rather
mathematical and it is constructed via
interpreting information from incoming
light signals
indeed for this background frame to
represent something physically real the
assumptions about the behavior of Light
which go into constructing it must
correspond to the actual behavior of
light so say our two observers start out
at rest with respect to each other and
to The
Ether if they construct their
backgrounds assuming that the speed of
light is everywhere constant and
isotropic as it truly physically is in
The Ether frame then their local frames
and their background frames will all
perfectly
align and everyone sees each other
exactly as they
are but now if we put one of the
observer's frames into motion two things
will happen in accordance with Loren's
Axiom the lengths of the moving frame
will physically
contract and the lengths of its temporal
durations will
dilate let's consider first just the
spatial aspect of the
problem since the background of the
unmoving Observer remains unchanged they
see the moving Observer as they truly
are physically
contracted but now the moving Observer
has a choice if they accept that they
are in a moving frame meaning they
accept that light behavior in their
frame is
anisotropic then consequently they can
maintain the validity of the original
background and they will agree that the
unmoving Observer is longer than
themselves
but if they want to maintain the idea
that light behavior in their frame is
still isotropic that is if they want to
reject the notion that anything physical
happened in their
frame then they will have to remap their
shortened lengths back to the proper
lengths they had in the original ether
frame but remapping or growing their
lengths means growing their background
as
well and since the moving obser has to
use this background to see the
non-moving frame The non-moving Observer
will now appear to be contracted
relative to
them even though of course it's their
own lengths which are truly physically
contracted less abstractly we can
reframe this by saying that as a moving
observer's lengths physically contract
in order to offset this shrinking and
continue maintaining the invariance of
their proper length
the observer's notion of what
constitutes length must consequently
grow traveling at high velocities
relative to the medium thus causes an
observer to perceive lengths about them
Contracting all the while in reality
it's their own lengths which are
physically
Contracting similarly for time as a
moving obser temporal durations
physically
dilate their notion of what constitutes
time must consequently contract in order
for them to maintain an invariant proper
time and thus relative to them other
clocks will run
slow one may clearly recognize in this
the mathematical principle of
contravariance that is since any
measurement involves both an amount and
a unit unit one can always compensate
for a decrease in amount by increasing
their notion of what constitutes the
unit alas this contravariant interplay
between an observer's local and velocity
dependent background means an observer
can always claim that their shorten
lengths or dilated times aren't actually
physical but rather the consequence of
other observers in motion wielding
inflated
backgrounds between two observers then
if both refuse to acknowledge any
physical difference between their local
frames what you will arrive at is a
theory with perfect symmetry but zero
physicality you are thus trapped in The
Matrix but if you already know how can I
make a choice because you didn't come
here to make the choice you've already
made it you're here to try to understand
why you
made at last we're ready to go back to
our initial scenario and ask what really
happens when your friend gets on a
rocket ship and travels to
Mars well essentially there's two main
cases we can
consider in the first case we start by
assuming the ether is at rest with
respect to the Earth and Mars in this
case when your friend travels at near
the speed of light his clocks really do
physically slow down and so he arrives
on Mars having aged less than
you he meanwhile only perceives the
distance between Earth and Mars to be
contracted in contravariant consequence
to his own lengths actually physically
having
contracted likewise he also only
perceives your clocks ticking
slowly in cont exra variant consequence
to his own temporal durations being
physically
lengthened now in the second case we
instead assume that the Earth and Mars
are in motion with respect to the ether
and moreover traveling through it at a
velocity such that your friend is
actually at rest with respect to the
ether during his
trip now in this case the distance
between Earth and Mars is really
physically
contracted but since you on Earth are in
motion you map that shorter distance as
being longer than it
is once your friend is at rest relative
to The Ether his lengths physically grow
and consequently he no longer Maps the
distance between Earth and Mars as being
longer than it is and thus the real
contracted distance between Earth and
Mars is revealed to
him his clocks then tick in accordance
with true time during his trip while
yours tick slow slowly until he
decelerates to land on Mars during which
he will be required to start remapping
both lengths and times once
more between these two cases we can note
that the end results are exactly the
same making it impossible to distinguish
between
them that is it's impossible to know
whose time dilation and whose length
contraction were physically real and
whose were merely a result of
coordinative constructions
this isn't some conspiracy however but
rather the consequence of reaching an
epistemological ceiling a possible limit
to our
knowledge to be an observer
fundamentally means to live in a matrix
of our consciousness's own making and
relativity was the first Theory to
fundamentally strike up against this
fact this platonic
barrier indeed Einstein's most striking
Insight was in recognizing that before
we as observers can even make any
empirical measurements at all we have to
make a choice of background which in the
context of special relativity means
making an assumption about the behavior
of
light now as we discussed in our prior
video the particular conclusion Einstein
Drew from this Insight was unfortunately
wrong as contrary to what he wrote it is
possible to Define time without assuming
invariant isotropic light Behavior
moreover as we further demonstrated by
adopting the right set of synchronicity
values observers can always agree on
Notions of space and
time however even if we impose a master
frame upon all observers we could never
be certain whether such a frame were
truly The Ether frame meaning we can
never be certain if the time dilation
and length contraction we observe
relative to that frame are physically
real or merely
corative but a lack of certainty doesn't
imply we should consequently reject the
notion of physical objective reality
indeed to believe a light beam magically
Alters Its Behavior based on who is
observing it as Einstein's postulate has
always undeniably implied is the height
of
pseudoscience if we want to escape such
solipsistic thinking if we want to
escape the matrix then we need only
acknowledge that there is indeed a real
physical difference between any two in
inertial frames in motion and that it is
in fact the phenomena of time dilation
and length contraction which precisely
reveals this difference to
us with all this in mind we can now
summarize the essential tenant of Matrix
Theory as follows first there exists two
types of time dilation and length
contraction the real world physical time
dilation and length contraction and the
Matrix world coordinative time dilation
and length
contraction Einstein's theory treats
only of the corative type and
consequently offers no explanation for
the physical
type Loren's Theory alone treats only of
the physical type and consequently
offers no explanation for the corative
type in combination however the theories
demonstrate that it is precisely the
physical time dilation and physical
length contraction of observers in
motion relative to the medium which in
leading them to wield inflated
backgrounds causes coordinative time
dilation and coordinative length
contraction secondly the mathematical
principle of contravariance requires a
symmetric interplay between the corative
Matrix world and the physical real
world the highly prized symmetry of
Relativity is thus not a feature of
reality rather merely a feature of
mathematics that that is of our own
Consciousness similarly the inability to
detect The Ether or equivalently the
one-way speed of light problem is a
consequence of the fact that all
measurement is relative to The Ether
thus The Ether itself cannot be measured
without invoking
circularity and this is in fact the
source of
Relativity but of course the mystery
remains what is it about motion relative
to The Ether that causes physical time
dilation and physical length contraction
to begin
with here is where the power of Matrix
Theory really begins to
shine because more so than offering us
an escape from mathematical
solipsism more so than revealing to us
the interdependency of the lorenzian and
einsteinian World Views we'll find that
with a little hard work Matrix theory of
unfurls the causal mechanisms for
physical time dilation and physical
length contraction right before our very
feet indeed we are about to discover
where all a truly physical theory of
wave mechanics can lead
us this has been
dialect stay
[Music]
tuned